okay Jimmy this is the year that VR
arrives by the end of the year if
PlayStation VR oculus rift the HTC vive
which is partnered with valve and it may
be difficult for some consumers to pick
between them because although they're
all virtual reality headsets they all
have different things to offer not just
in terms of hardware but also the games
and the platforms associated with them
PlayStation VR is the newest one it
comes out next week we've had a chance
to use it so I'm curious what you think
PlayStation VR is for people who want to
get into VR and who it's best for I
think that the PS VR is for people who
already have ps4s who are interested in
getting into VR it's also the most
affordable option to me it does make
some compromises because it does use
existing peripherals that weren't that
weren't designed for VR so like for
instance unlike the HTC vive it doesn't
have room scale so you can't like turn
360 you can't walk around your living
room you know kind of mix compromises it
is fair to say though that maybe even
like the five right which does have
those room scale VR capabilities and
experience is available for it they're
not all that great right so if you look
down the line VR could get cheaper down
the road it probably will like a lot of
technology and the software will catch
up but today do you think someone is
missing out if they choose a PlayStation
VR over the HTC vive like is it worth
the extra investment to get maybe those
middling room-scale experiences today so
I think when the HTC vive launched a lot
of the games were sort of they're mostly
Mis I would say but since they've since
you know the headset has launched a lot
of good titles have come out the onward
is really good to first-person military
style shooter raw data is like another
sort of co-op shooter experience where
you're like killing cyborgs with a
friend and then there's like valves the
lab which you know has a compilation of
mini-games
an archery one that's like that I like a
lot so I think to me that is the system
that has the
promise okay it's also got a lot more
moving parts right there's a lot more to
set up and account also the most
expenses also yeah exactly and you know
again when we're talking about you know
PCs and gaming pcs especially for VR you
need a pretty powerful system when you
add up all of that the cost and the
complications involved do you think for
the average consumer the vibe is the
right fit or is it really just for early
adopters at this stage so it is
something that's definitely for
enthusiasts I think you'll need a $700
VR PC to play it I built one which
that's like basically the cheapest that
I could build one for and then the
headset itself is like eight hundred
dollars yeah
and that $800 is as expensive as a
PlayStation 4 and the PSV are complete
bundle which includes like the camera
that you need and like the Move
controllers um so it is definitely the
steepest barrier to entry but for me I
think if you're serious about getting
into VR um I think it's worth it now I'm
not saying that the vibe is perfect a
lot of the games are self-aware I will
admit to that and the one big area to me
that psvr has the leg up is in its
comfort and ergonomics sure it's
actually slightly heavier but it's much
more comfortable because the way is
balanced better whereas the vibe is very
front heavy and kind of squeezes into
your face and also the vibe is is really
difficult to set up as sophisticated
like lighthouse trackers that you have
to like mount to your walls then you
have like sort of map out of your room
so that's kind of a pain in the butt
PS VR is much easier to set up so then
in the middle that leaves oculus rift
right it is perhaps as easy to set up as
a PlayStation VR but it also has the
same limitations in some ways now we
know that oculus will be releasing
controllers and another you know
tracking sensor but so you know assume
those are out maybe not how good they
work but in terms of what they're going
to offer
how does then oculus compare to those
two and what would be the right reason
for someone to choose an oculus rift
over PlayStation VR or vive today so for
me it's not really full VR until you can
get your hands into the experience and
yeah you did mention that touch is right
around the corner unfortunately it's not
yet it should be coming out this year I
can't really attest to how good those
are until I review them so it's hard to
say I personally think that the oculus
is missing out on not having those track
controllers which PlayStation VR does
have over it with the Move controller
right so I guess if you had to pick one
today for yourself you know how would
you describe yourself in your gaming
habits and how would a specific VR
headset suit you best
today so to me like going back to the
full immersive experience
I think getting your hands in TV ours is
one large component of that but also
being able to like walk around which the
vibe offers they have a system called
room scale that allows you to like walk
around your you know limited play space
and that to me that to me adds a lot
lots of people probably going to say in
the comments VR is a gimmick it's like
the Wii motion controllers or whatever
plus like maybe 3d TVs on top of that
but to me it's it's it's totally
different it when there's a good VR
experience your mind in your body at
least for me feels present in that
moment and I want that too don't get me
wrong I just feel like the software
isn't there to make me invest the extra
money at this point I'm actually totally
happy with what I'm getting out of the
PlayStation VR after playing a few games
right it's not fully immersive
virtual-reality but it's still a step
above I think the the standard games we
play and even above 3d and we modes like
that combination even that PlayStation
VR is way ahead of that and for me right
now because I see so many great things
coming in the years to come
I'm kind of more focused on today
because I know in the future of your
headsets are going to be cheaper they're
going to be better so I'm totally happy
with PlayStation VR just speaking for
myself just because it's super
comfortable it's really easy to set up
and I like the games I'm playing even
though they aren't really like the
highest-end VR experiences yet fair
enough yeah well so we know which VR
headsets we want which one are you
interested in the most let us know in
the comments below there's a lot more VR
coverage on the way for all of it stay
tuned to game spot calm
you